hi everybody i'm jonathan trance and I  have another tactical puzzle for you so  when you see the position on your screen  go ahead and pause your video and see if  you can solve the puzzle so here's your  puzzle in this position it's white to  move are you ready for the solution here  it comes in this position white has a  winning attack based off of a really  cool check mating pattern after Queen  takes rook the black King has to take  back and now White has a forced mate in  two after the move rook to e8 King to g7  and rook to g8 we have an Arabian mate  and White has won the game I hope you  enjoyed this video congratulations to  all of you guys that were able to get  this puzzle right it was a little bit  trickier so good job if you got this one  if you want to see more great stuff like  this please subscribe to our YouTube  channel thank you for watching